a mayday march is also set to happen
this evening on the las vegas strip it
starts near valleys and organizers say
they're demanding stronger worker
protections in advocating for
immigration rights mary jane belliesa
joins us live near flamingo and las
vegas boulevard with the details mary
jane
sasha good evening that march is
expected to get underway here within the
next hour and a number of community
organizations are expected to meet here
near the bellagio fountains now this may
also recognizes international workers
day and las vegas immigrant workers and
community members are marching to demand
a pathway to citizenship and permanent
protections a number of organizations
will be in attendance including make the
road nevada and the national domestic
workers alliance just name a few they
hope their voices will be heard as they
fight for the many immigrant workers who
call america home now coming up at six
we're going to hear from those marching
for immigrant rights so stay with us
here on channel eight and we'll have the
latest on that reporting live from the
ship mary jane bellassa live local now